Verset 22, mais les fruits de l'esprit c'est l'amour, la joie.
Et donc ici nous sommes devant un passage où l'apôtre Paul est en train de présenter les fruits de l'esprit avec un mot qui fait référence au contraste.
Donc c'est mais, les fruits de l'esprit.
Donc l'intention de l'apôtre Paul, nous qui sommes en train d'étudier la lettre des Paul aux Galates, nous sommes déjà plus habitués.
Il y a une dispute à cette église où des judaïsants, des personnes qui s'est déclaré chrétien,
mais qui étaient encore plus accrochées à l'idolâtrie de leur tradition juive,
ils sont rentrés, ils ont pénétré dans cette église qui était composée majoritairement par des péliants qui ont vraiment connu l'évangile.
Et ils étaient en train de réjouir les Galates de la vraie joie, de la vraie liberté,
la joie d'être enfant de Dieu sans avoir la moindre possibilité de mettre en doute l'amour paternel des dieux envers eux
et la perpétuité inébranlable de leur statut en tant qu'enfant de Dieu, un Christ devant Dieu.
Ils n'avaient aucune crainte de perdre les saluts par exemple.
Ils étaient plutôt rassurés qu'ils étaient convertis.
Mais cette hérésie a pénétré par les judaïsants qui pensaient que non seulement Christ était nécessaire pour nous sauver,
pour pourvoir la justice parfaite qu'on n'arrive pas à présenter devant Dieu,
mais même si Christ a fait un bon travail sur les points de départ, il fallait que nous-mêmes par nos efforts,
nous maintenions notre salut, notre relation avec Dieu par nos œuvres, par notre performance religieuse.
Cette hérésie, elle est pénétrée
et une dispute a commencé à avoir lieu dans cette église.
Ceux qui étaient rassurés de leur joie, de leur paix,
certains d'entre les Galates ont cédé à la pression judaïsante
et ont commencé à mener une relation névrotique envers Dieu,
avec la peur de perdre les saluts,
étant à point même de se permettre de se faire circoncire.
L'enseignement de Paul, c'est que Christ,
il non seulement a fait une œuvre parfaite au point de départ,
mais il a fait une œuvre parfaite qui assure la réussite pour toute la longueur.
Les comportements de ces hommes sont arrivés à tel point dans la division dans cette église
que certains qui ont exagéré sur les faits,
qu'ils les saluent, se donnent par la grâce seule,
Christ a tout accompli.
Ils étaient à point aussi peut-être de suggérer
que comme Christ a tout fait, je n'ai plus besoin de rien faire.
Et comme la grâce de Christ a tout pardonné,
je peux peut-être me livrer à nouveau
dans mes pratiques pécheresses.
Et l'apôtre Paul, pour corriger toute cette situation,
il est en train d'écrire plutôt ce qui est un chrétien
au lieu de présenter des conditions
que les personnes devraient chercher à accomplir
pour se considérer chrétien.
Pour Paul, la grande question c'est
est-ce que nous sommes ou non chrétiens
et comment pouvons-nous évaluer
si nous sommes ou non chrétiens
ou non chrétiens
et si nous sommes sûrs d'être chrétiens.
C'est clair que nous avons la capacité
pourvue par l'esprit qui habite en nous
de manifester les évidences d'être un enfant des dieux.
Donc les fruits de l'esprit ici
est une exhortation à cette église
pour que certains d'entre les judaïsants
qui auraient pu être véritablement chrétiens
ne manifestent pas un comportement dissonant
de cette symétrie glorieuse
qui est présentée dans les fruits de l'esprit.
si ces hommes-là ont un zèle
pour l'obéissance ou l'observation de la loi
si ces zèles sont légitimes
ils seront accompagnés d'amour, de joie, de douceur, etc.
Mais les plus légalistes
et tous ceux qui ont déjà croisé les légalistes dans leur vie
perçoivent clairement que ces personnes manquent de joie.
Manquent d'amour, manquent de patience, de douceur.
Ce sont les policiers de la foi.
Et en même temps, de l'autre côté
ceux qui auraient pu être en train de dire
donc Christ a tout fait
je n'ai plus besoin de rien faire
je peux me lancer dans mes péchés car il a tout payé
ils sont aussi en train de montrer
qu'ils ne sont pas vraiment convertis
ils ne sont pas des vrais chrétiens
ils n'ont pas les fruits de l'esprit
car les fruits de l'esprit
ils se portent aussi envers la bonté
ou plutôt la sainteté ou la droiture
et une vie qui cherche les plaisirs charnels
ne représente pas une vie d'amour
pour les choses les plus élevées
comme la sainteté et Dieu lui-même.
Donc Paul, il va faire un échec mat
devant les deux
disformités de l'évangile dans cette communauté
en présentant que la question finale
est est-ce que vous avez reçu l'esprit ou non ?
et si vous avez reçu l'esprit
et vous êtes véritablement né de nouveau
vous avez été fait enfant des dieux
et un enfant des dieux
manifeste les caractères des dieux
dans sa vie pratique.
Un vrai enfant des dieux
a pour plus grand but
pour plus grande joie
d'être obéissant vers Dieu
donc il n'est pas motivé par la crainte
ou les terrorisme de perdre son salut
il est motivé par les désirs
de plaire Dieu son Seigneur.
Et donc, lorsqu'on est devant
les fruits de l'esprit
on est devant une évidence.
Et là, la déclaration
qui va couvrir tous ces contextes-là
c'est que les fruits de l'esprit
sont nécessaires et suffisants
pour qu'on identifie un vrai enfant des dieux.
Et à partir du moment
où on identifie un enfant des dieux
et qu'on cherche à le corriger
il a tout ce qu'il faut
par la présence de son esprit
et par sa nouvelle nature
de se laisser redresser
de faire quelque part
une activation de sa nouvelle nature
et cette église
pourrait revenir au bon ordre
juste par les rappels
de qui ils sont en Christ
les puissances qu'ils ont
et l'exhortation à marcher
selon la nouvelle nature
selon l'esprit.
Et donc, les fruits de l'esprit
ici n'est pas une condition
atteignable pour toutes les personnes
c'est une réalité naturelle
organique par la liaison
entre les chrétiens et Christ
par l'esprit
des branches greffées à Christ
et la vie du Christ
va se manifester à travers nous
par l'esprit.
Donc on a compris en fait
ces phénomènes glorieux
qui a la nouvelle nature
qui a la nouvelle identité
du chrétien
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que ces exhortations
ont été efficaces
car on n'a pas
une deuxième lettre
au Galate.
Cette église
a beaucoup plus d'évidence
pour son redressement
sa correction.
Et en ayant considéré
ces aspects
importants
nous ne sommes pas
devant une condition
pour les saluts
nous sommes devant
une manifestation
des vrais enfants
des dieux
nous sommes passés
à la considération
de chaque facette
particulière
du fruit de l'esprit.
On a commencé
il y a deux dimanches
avec la considération
de l'amour
et l'amour
il apparaît
en premier
surtout en considérant
que les fruits de l'esprit
sont dans les sangliers
et l'amour
il devient
la vertu
ou la facette capitale
de ces fruits
étant responsable
pour déclencher
toutes les autres vertus
et pour intégrer
de manière parfaitement
équilibrée
toutes ces autres vertus.
Donc un chrétien
véritable
ne peut pas démontrer
tout simplement
quelques
de ces vertus
il doit les manifester
toutes
et les goûts
qui vont ressortir
de sa vie
de la vie qu'elle mène
c'est les goûts
de l'amour.
C'est une personne aimable
car elle aime
et c'est une personne
qui n'est pas en train
d'aimer
comme le monde peut aimer
c'est une personne
qui est en train
d'aimer
un Christ.
Il reçoit
l'amour de Dieu
par Christ
et l'amour de Dieu
envers toutes les choses
que Dieu aime
se manifeste
à travers nos vies
de manière profondément
expérimentale.
Et donc on a compris
que l'amour
quand on a donné
l'illustration
de la clémentine
il est comme si
on était devant
les fibres
qui unissent
tous les gommes
toutes les parties
il est comme si
on était devant
les goûts
qui ressortent
de la vie chrétienne
et on a compris
qu'elle est surtout
enracinée
et centrée
sur Christ
et son évangile.
Je vous encourage
à revenir
pour considérer
ces prédications
qui sont à disposition
en ligne
et nous allons avancer
pour considérer
la prochaine facette.
Et donc
si la vérité
pour nous
la semaine dernière
c'était
qu'à fond
d'identifier
et à fond
de maximiser
l'expérience
du fruit de l'esprit
ou de l'amour
de l'esprit
aujourd'hui
on va considérer
comment nous pouvons
identifier
et cultiver
intentionnellement
la joie
de l'esprit.
La grande question
pour nous
c'est
est-ce qu'on a déjà
expérimenté
ce type de joie
et si nous avons
expérimenté
ce type de joie
comment nous pouvons
maximiser
notre expérience
avec la joie chrétienne.
A partir du moment
où la Bible
nous montre
que les fruits
de l'esprit
et l'amour
et la joie
et l'ordre
elle est toujours
très importante
dans la Bible
nous sommes devant
une description
biblique
inspirée
par le Saint-Esprit
de ce qui est
les chrétiens.
Et donc tout de suite
c'est clair
et évident
pour nous tous
qu'un chrétien
qui n'aime pas
et qui n'est pas
joyeux
est une aberration
selon
les écritures.
C'est possible
que les chrétiens
traversent des moments
difficiles
particulièrement
où il a du mal
à expérimenter la joie
mais par contre
la Bible nous montre
que même
dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles
c'est possible
qu'un chrétien
soit dans la joie
rempli de gloire.
Et donc
c'est une incohérence
et une aberration.
Donc comment nous pouvons
constater cette joie
dans nos vies
et comment nous pouvons
maximiser
l'expérience
et la manifestation
de cette joie
c'est la question
centrale pour nous
et la première réponse
c'est que pour constater
maximiser la joie
de l'esprit
les croyants
doivent connaître
et avoir
un désir profond
et progressif
pour expérimenter
la joie
de l'esprit.
Donc
le premier point
veut tout simplement dire
nous devons
au moins
avoir connu
une fois
dans notre vie
au moins
de manière
profonde
et expérimentale
la joie
de l'esprit
du Christ
la joie
des dieux
issue
de l'amour
des dieux
pour nous
révélée en Christ
dans l'œuvre
de la rédemption
et cette joie
a dû
devenir
une caractéristique
constante
prédominante
dans notre vie
et elle doit
faire
au moins
au fond
de notre cœur
car si nous sommes
sous
les mauvaises influences
les pressions culturelles
les déviations
la mauvaise direction
qui nous donne
les faux prophètes
de regarder
la prospérité
aujourd'hui et maintenant
temporelle
matérielle
si nous n'avons pas
des interférences
dans nos vies
au fond du cœur
de tous les chrétiens
il sait très bien
que sa plus
parfaite joie
se trouve
dans sa communion
intime
avec l'amour
des dieux
et l'amour
du Christ
si nous avons déjà
connu cette joie
nous devons
identifier
aussi dans le cœur
un désir
pour expérimenter
de plus en plus
cette joie
et de manifester
de plus en plus
cette joie
parce qu'il est versé
avant 2
nous dit
mais
les fruits de l'esprit
en faisant contraste
avec notre vie
passée
et prégrès
avec les œuvres
de la chair
il est en train
de nous manifester
que tous les chrétiens
et que les chrétiens
ont connu
cette joie
expérimentent
comme
tout comme
le Saint-Esprit
nous a été donné
de manière permanente
et comme l'un des rôles
principaux
du Saint-Esprit
c'est de nous faire
expérimenter
la joie
des dieux en Christ
tous les chrétiens
véritables
sont constamment
exhortés
par les Saint-Esprits
à expérimenter
de plus en plus
cette joie
et tous les chrétiens
doivent donc
être marqués
par cette joie
c'est-à-dire
si la constance
la prédominance
et les désirs
les plus profonds
de mon cœur
ne se dirigent pas
vers la joie
généré par l'Esprit
la joie
trouvée en Dieu
et en Christ
je dois douter
de l'authenticité
de mon salut
bien sûr
que cette joie
représente
notre santé
psychique
et on pourrait
utiliser des arguments
et ça c'est
une certitude
absolue
la plupart
des soi-disant
chrétiens
dépressifs
attristés
la seule raison
c'est car
ils sont en train
de donner
beaucoup plus
d'écoute
aux inclinations
corrompues
de la chair
les restes
chez nous
qu'il y a
de se concentrer
sur ce qui fait
l'objet
de notre joie
à cause
de la sublimité
de notre source
de joie
comme on verra
et à cause
de la constance
de cette source
de joie
qui est toujours
à notre disposition
comme chrétiens
les plus les chrétiens
véritables
cultivent cette joie
les plus ils s'efforcent
pour aller dans la direction
du Saint-Esprit
à cet égard
les plus on sera
capable
d'expérimenter
une vie
transitoire
ici-bas
dans ce monde
marqué par les afflictions
caractérisé
par la joie
la joie
sera la constance
de notre vie
notre problème
c'est pas
qu'on n'a pas encore
consulté
un psychanalyste
ou qu'on devrait
peut-être
augmenter
la dose
des psychotropes
notre problème
c'est qu'on n'est pas
en train de chercher
c'est qu'il y a
la seule chose
qui peut régler
à la racine
les problèmes
de l'humanité
et qui nous avons
déjà connus
en tant que chrétien
donc même
pour notre
bien-être
si vous voulez dire
comme ça
notre expérience
de vie
notre santé psychique
en tant que chrétien
dépend
d'être focalisé
sur cette source
de joie
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
que l'intérêt
de Satan
est le premier
à supprimer
particulièrement
cette source
de joie
chez les chrétiens
car selon
les écritures
l'une des puissances
les plus
évangélistiques
qui possède
l'église
pensez-vous
avec la stratégie
de Satan
s'il ne peut pas
voler les saluts
des vrais convertis
s'il ne peut jamais
enlever
les saint-esprit
de la vie
des ceux
qui sont
vraiment convertis
quelle est la
deuxième chose
la plus bénéfique
pour l'empire
des ténèbres
c'est
de rendre
la foi chrétienne
non attirante
et comment
nous pouvons rendre
la foi chrétienne
non attirante
surtout en supprimant
la joie du salut
lorsqu'on va
en génération
des chrétiens
très mélancoliques
attristés
tous les temps
en ayant
leur attention
dirigée toujours
vers ceux
qu'ils pensent
manquer
dans leur vie
plutôt que
concentrés
sur ceux
qu'ils ont
déjà en Christ
nous voyons
surtout
une génération
faible
envers
l'évangélisation
par les banques
des joies
car nous vivons
dans une culture
qui cherche
à nous conduire
envers
toutes les sortes
d'idolâtrie
vers la prospérité
financière
les succès
professionnels
parce qu'on voit
tous les moyens
de communication
les personnes
donnent la façade
d'être toujours
dans la joie
et en même temps
toutes les données
statistiques montrant
qui nous sont
dans les pays
qui sont les plus
grands consommateurs
des psychotropes
de nos jours
c'est une culture
marquée par ces deux
extrêmes
d'embrasser
la victimisation
et la dépression
d'un côté
et par là
saisissant
beaucoup
d'attention
et des supports
même de la part
de l'État
et de l'autre côté
en suggérant
un mensonge
d'être si facile
de trouver
une sorte
de bonheur
une bonheur
qui n'est qu'évecue
par la façade
et donc si
au milieu
d'une génération
plutôt dépressive
les croyants
ne sont pas
ceux qui attirent
les autres
par leur joie
ces autres
idoles
et mensonges
vont attirer
beaucoup plus
les personnes
que l'Église
Némi
dans le chapitre 8
verset 10
il dit
« Ne vous affligez pas
car la joie
de l'Éternel
est votre force »
C'est notre force
même envers
l'évangélisation
Proverbe 15-13
nous dit
« Un cœur joyeux
rend les visages
serrants »
Dans l'original
c'est plutôt
un visage
embéi
Il illumine
les visages
Il fait luire
Il rend
les visages
radieux
Mais quand
le cœur
est attristé
l'esprit
est abattu
Donc quand on voit
la pression
que les cultures
exercent
sur l'Église
dans tous les lieux
du monde
nous devons être
conscients
de comment
notre culture
peut être
en train
de nous affecter
et considérer
que malheureusement
nous sommes dans
une culture
dépressive
qui est addictique
à la distraction
au plaisir
superficiel
momentané
et des fois
cherche
par des moyens
irraisonnables
non rationnels
de guérir
leur problématique
des manques
de satisfaction
Donc lorsqu'on pense
d'un côté
les psychotropes
qui ne traitent
jamais la racine
des problèmes
et qui ne font
que l'agrandir
et qui doivent
par là
agrandir les doses
pour suspendre
les bons fonctionnements
de la raison
et l'autre côté
ceux qui s'élancent
dans les drogues
pour chercher
à travers
une expérience
d'extase
sans raisonnement
un type
de plaisir
et si nous pensons
à l'état
de l'église
aujourd'hui
nous pouvons voir
parfois
comment certaines églises
promettent
la joie
comme Satan
promit à Christ
lorsqu'il a voulu
tenter les Christ
à tomber
la gloire du monde
domestiquer Dieu
pour que Dieu
devienne
les sponsors
de leur idolâtrie
de leur plaisir
charnel
nous voyons
comment
beaucoup d'églises
veulent
diriger
l'égard
des chrétiens
à des nouées
sans eau
comme si
les mieux
des dieux
n'étaient pas
déjà venus
mais encore
à venir
c'est intéressant
car ces mêmes
types d'églises
de manière générale
sont celles
qui suggèrent
une espèce
d'émotionalisme
chrétien
où nous allons
réclamer
comme œuvre
de Saint-Esprit
des expériences
des joies
d'extase
sans avoir
les racontes
des racines
objectives
raisonnables
pour ancrer
notre joie
la joie
selon la Bible
est toujours
intégrale
avec cet amour
que nous devons avoir
pour Dieu
de tout notre cœur
c'est-à-dire
de toute notre pensée
de toute notre affection
et de toutes nos forces
et si la joie
n'est pas
enracinée
sur ces vérités
glorieuses
qui font notre joie
c'est ce que Dieu
a fait pour nous
dans l'histoire
la gloire
que Dieu possède
dans ses vertus
cette joie
sera si éphémère
que la joie du monde
et donc
particulièrement
dans la génération
nous les chrétiens
on doit faire attention
à cette phrase
de la joie du monde
qui dit
un chrétien misérable
est une contradiction
en soi
et rien n'ennuie plus
l'évangile
de donner l'impression
que le christianisme
est quelque chose
de triste
de morgue
et là nous devons
déjà faire quelques observations
car pour ne pas être
précipité dans un esprit
de jugement
être très dur
envers les autres
ou peut-être
envers nous-mêmes
il faut savoir
que la manière
de réagir à la joie
peut varier
de personne à personne
et des fois
une personne
qui pleure
peut être en train
d'expérimenter
la vraie joie
mais parfois
l'impression
c'est que
ce qui doit
prédominer
chez les églises
est la culture
du pleur
certains pleurent
pour tout
et pour rien
c'est-à-dire
des fois
on va
prier
et même si
on est en train
de prier
pour un sujet
de célébration
de réjouissance
la personne
commence à pleurer
lorsqu'elle va prier
car elle pense
que la culture
des prières
c'est ça
on a l'impression
parfois
que
tout service
à l'église
doit être sérieux
austère
dans l'apathie
la piété
est confondue
avec un état
apathique
de l'âme
c'est sûr
que nous
pouvons traverser
des graves épreuves
qui ne prennent pas
surprise
et qui rendent
difficile
les sourires
mais si nous sommes
devant
des difficultés
qui peuvent
perdurer
nous n'avons pas
les droits
en tant que chrétien
de nous dire
tant que je sois
dans la tente
j'essaierai
en train de pleurer
car nous faisons
confiance
en Dieu
qui a promis
que toutes les choses
vont converger
à notre bien
les modèles
qui nous trouvons
dans les écritures
c'est comme
l'apôtre Paul
emprisonné
qui va écrire
la lettre
de la joie
de l'allégresse
philippien
réjouissez
dans les seigneurs
je vous exhorte
à nouveau
réjouissez
dans les seigneurs
et toutes les pages
de la bible
quand on va
vers l'ancien testament
nous voyons
les mêmes dieux
des joies
les dieux
des fêtes
des célébrations
les dieux
du refuge
de David
qui est lorsqu'il était
persécuté
par son fils
lui-même
de manière
très injuste
et qu'il souffrait
énormément
ce sont les psaumes
les plus beaux
qui nous déclarent
combien des joies
nous trouvons
dans la présence
des dieux
notre souverain
bien
notre seul bien
une joie
qui ne dépend
pas des circonstances
mais heureusement
que nous trouvons
aussi dans notre milieu
des personnes
qui traversent
des difficultés
énormes
et parfois
on n'en a même pas
conscience
et des fois
ils sont en train
de nous entendre
partager nos fardeaux
et là c'est légitime
il ne faut pas supprimer
la demande de l'aide
de l'église
mais ça nous ferait
un bien énorme
de savoir
que la personne
à qui nous cherchons
pour demander
de la prière
de l'aide
de la compréhension
pour écouter
nos difficultés
si on savait
combien de difficultés
beaucoup plus profondes
ils sont en train
de traverser
en gardant
le sourire
et la joie
Dieu nous appelle
non à vivre
adapté à notre culture
mais être
en train
de vivre
une vie adaptée
à la culture céleste
à la réalité
de cette joie
donc afin de constater
maximiser
la manifestation
de la joie
de l'esprit
nous devons
avant tout
nous assurer
qu'on a déjà goûté
une fois dans notre vie
d'une joie
qui surmonte
les circonstances
et nous rappeler
que cette joie
doit être
une caractéristique
constante
et prédominante
dans notre vie
elle est
à notre disposition
car elle dépend
exclusivement
de la présence
de son esprit
et de notre réconciliation
avec Dieu
ça c'est la première chose
à savoir
à reconnaître
pour arrêter
avec cette prédisposition
marquée par la culture
d'un victimisme
envers la vie
l'église
elle est un hôpital
et pendant une période
nous tous
nous avons les droits
et des saisons
de partager
les fardeaux
chercher l'aide
l'église
mais notre vie
ne peut pas être marquée
à long terme
par les manques
de joie
et par la tristesse
afin de constater
et maximiser
la manifestation
de la joie
de l'esprit
nous devons aussi
connaître
l'authenticité
et l'efficacité
de cette joie
face aux contrefaçons
de l'évangile
donc comment nous trouvons
cette vérité dans les textes
je vais formuler
de manière plus claire
et l'objectif des policiers
lorsqu'ils disent
mais
le fruit de l'esprit
c'est un contraste
avec les œuvres
de la chair
et quand on revient
vers le contexte
comme je vous ai avancé
à l'introduction
nous avons une église
divisée
par deux
fausses versions
de l'évangile
dans un extrême
nous sommes devant
les légalistes
les policiers
de la foi
les pharisiens
ceux qui vont suggérer
que
la bénédiction
et la joie
dépendent
de notre
performance
religieuse
pour expérimenter
la joie
d'être approuvé
par Dieu
et s'assurer
que Dieu va agir
à notre faveur
nous devons toujours
avoir la sensation
que nous sommes en train
de presque vivre
une vie parfaite
selon les termes
de la loi
c'est une sorte
de terrorisme
gospel
motivé
par les menaces
ou
par des récompenses
mécaniques
la joie
devient
quelque chose
de préconditionné
par la performance
religieuse
selon leurs critères
leurs termes
et donc
lorsqu'il peut lui dire
les fruits de l'esprit
et la joie
il est en train
de faire
que la joie
soit
une vertu
si puissante
capable
de pulvériser
et écraser
toutes les œuvres
de la chair
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc l'exercice
important pour nous
c'est de revenir
au verset 19
à 21
et dans un premier moment
observer
comment la joie
va se confronter
au péché
des légalistes
et de cette fausse version
de l'évangile
au sein de l'église
Paul insiste
les saluts du chrétien
se donnent par la foi
c'est une justice étrangère
c'est Christ
qui est venu
accomplir la loi
parfaitement à ma place
qui est mort à la croix
pour payer
pour la punition
que j'ai mérité
donc ma dette
elle est complètement
acquittée devant Dieu
pour toute l'éternité
il a payé
pour mes péchés
passés
présents
futurs
et c'est par la foi
en Jésus Christ
que j'ai méprisant
devant le tribunal
des dieux
il n'y a plus rien
à accomplir
de ma part
en termes
d'observation légale
mais ceux qui cherchent
par leurs propres efforts
à accomplir la loi
ils finissent
pour être encore
esclaves de la chair
d'une manière
assez surprenante
c'est
la sensation
d'avoir une justice propre
méritoire
de conquérir son droit
d'être sauvé par Dieu
d'être béni par Dieu
et donc
qu'est-ce qui caractérise
les plus
un légaliste
c'est
déjà
et tout de suite
l'absence
de la joie
authentique
c'est
un orgueil
d'avoir
réussi
à accomplir
la loi
selon
ses critères
et ses observations
et dans la surface
on peut penser
qu'ils sont très critérieux
alors des fois
ils sont couverts
de la tête
jusqu'aux pieds
ils sont en train
de se sacrifier
avec un agenda
très lourd
pour observer
la loi
à plusieurs regards
et leur vie
est marquée
par ces sérieux
par ces ailes
fanatiques
où ils ne peuvent
jamais relâcher
je donne cet exemple
à chaque fois
car il y a beaucoup
d'églises
jusqu'à nos jours
si quelqu'un
me donne la sensation
qu'il pourrait être béni
ou recevoir
cette bénédiction
des dieux
je ne peux rater
aucun des mercredis
des 70 semaines
de la campagne
je suis dans une relation
névrotique avec Dieu
ce n'est pas par grâce
ce n'est pas par les mérites
du Christ à la croix
ce n'est pas ma performance
religieuse
mais sacrifice
donc la vie
de cette personne
sera marquée
par le névrotisme
je peux perdre
la faveur des dieux
d'un moment à l'autre
ils sont caractérisés
peut-être
par
les faits
qu'ils sont fiers
et j'ai déjà entendu ça
du fait
qu'ils n'arrivent
même pas
à rigoler
d'une blague
c'est le terrorisme
c'est l'atmosphère
des menaces
et Paul insiste
que nous ne sommes plus
dans l'atmosphère
de l'esclavage
mais d'enfant
un enfant
il sait
que s'il rate
quelque chose
il s'est rattristé
car il veut plaire
son père
et ça suffit
pour sa répentance
et son redressement
mais il est assuré
que même en ayant
péché contre son père
son père ne va pas
les traiter
comme s'il était
un esclave
il ne va pas
les virer
les fouetter
surtout car
pour nous adopter
Dieu a déjà
puni son propre
fils à notre place
et c'est cette assurance
du pardon
assuré
qu'un enfant
va chercher
à confesser
et recevoir
la grâce
et la restauration
mais dans
ces ailes malades
ce que nous trouvons
dans la pratique
de ces hommes
sont les inimitiés
les querelles
les jalousies
les animosités
les disputes
les divisions
les sectes
et l'envie
donc comment
nous pouvons identifier
un pharisien
entre nous
c'est car
c'est soi-disant
zèle
pour les bonnes choses
pour l'ordre
de l'église
pour les progrès
de chrétiens
dans la surface
c'est pourtant
bien
que je suis là
en train d'être
exhorté
et le manque
de joie
fait qu'on se demande
si lui-même
il a connu
le vrai évangile
car c'est pas
avec une vie
caractérisée
par la joie
qu'il cherche
à m'attirer
à sa manière
de vivre
car si
cette manière
de vivre
représente
le christianisme
cette austérité
cette dureté
c'est sérieux
incapacité
d'avoir
une bonne humeur
de rire
de rigoler
les moments
où on souffre
en échec
on tombe par terre
quelque chose
de ridicule
se passe avec nous
au lieu de joindre
ceux qui vont rigoler
on est très préoccupé
avec notre réputation
notre respect
ce sont des indices
pas d'une personne
qui est en train
d'être débordée
d'assurance en Dieu
mais des indices
d'une personne
qui manque quelque chose
envie
elle est en train
d'envier
une joie légitime
de celui
qui a plus de liberté
à confesser
ses faiblesses
et qui cherche
à améliorer
car cette personne
est caractérisée
par la joie
de savoir
que Dieu
va pourvoir
les pardons
et la puissance
pour m'essentifier
et il a
tout simplement
la joie
d'être sûr
qu'il est un enfant
de Dieu
aimé
par contre
les légalistes
il n'arrive pas
à expérimenter
donc entre
toutes les choses
qu'il peut envier
d'un vrai chrétien
il envie
sa joie
sa liberté
et voilà pourquoi
ils étaient en train
d'exploiter
sévèrement
cette église
et ils étaient en train
d'engendrer
les inimitiés
les querelles
ce qui caractérise
leur manière
de traiter les différences
nous savons bien sûr
qu'il y a
certaines vérités capitales
pour lesquelles
Paul a lutté
de manière très ferme
au début de la lettre
si quelqu'un
prêche
un autre évangile
qui soit
en Athènes
et en même temps
il est en train
d'insister
avec un cœur
paternel
envers les Galates
pour les redresser
et son zèle majeur
c'est de protéger
leur joie
et leur liberté
leur assurance
du salut
en Jésus Christ
donc nous devons
savoir gérer
les différences
légitimes
entre nous
entre les églises
sans chercher
à nous discuter
pour chaque chose
secondaire
en essayant
d'uniformiser
la foi chrétienne
notre manière
de nous habiller
quel type
de récréation
nous ne pouvons
pas le faire
et donc
c'est un zèle malade
qui est aussi
caractérisé
par un système
des compétitions
on rentre
dans une église légaliste
et tout de suite
on voit déjà
rien que par la manière
dont ils organisent
l'église
à démontrer
les positions
l'ordre d'importance
ceux qui sont mis
en avance
et ce sont ceux
qui sont les plus capables
de défendre
avec zèle
les traditions
de l'église
on n'est pas
préoccupé
à manifester
la joie du Seigneur
on est préoccupé
à voir
qui sont ceux
qui sont
les plus assidus
ceux qui
respectent
les plus
les règles intérieures
de l'église
les pharisiens
ont rajouté
600 lois
aux lois
de la Bible
et donc là
on voit
comment dans
ces systèmes-là
on veut voir
déjà comment
les personnes
vont servir
et les personnes
sont là
motivées
par la jalousie
par les désirs
des positions
d'évidence
des pouvoirs
voilà pourquoi
ils se réclament
apôtres
même aujourd'hui
comme les judaïsants
le faisaient aussi
et c'est pour ça
que l'apôtre Paul
au verset 26
plus en avance
il va dire
ne cherchons pas
une vaine gloire
en nous provoquant
les uns les autres
en nous portant
envie les uns
sur les autres
là ce sont des réproches
particulièrement dirigées
au groupe
des judaïsants
quelle était leur vaine gloire
comme dans la parabole
du pharisiens
et du publican
les publicans
qui connaissaient
ces péchés
qui frappaient la poitrine
demandaient pardon à Dieu
et les pharisiens
qui disaient
moi je ne suis pas
comme ces publicans
la seule joie
qu'ils expérimentent
c'est la sensation
d'être plus juste
que les autres
et ça c'est complètement
une vaine gloire
la Bible dit
que leur sourire
les sourires
des hypocrites
sera bientôt
converti
en pleurs
mais de l'autre côté
nous voyons aussi
que les libertants
n'ont pas de place
non plus
dans la vraie
église du Christ
verset 19
il dit
or les oeuvres
de la chair
sont
et donc
si l'apôtre Paul
est en train
de présenter
la joie
contrairement
à ses oeuvres
c'est car
la joie
chrétienne
elle a la capacité
les chasser
les détruire
et pour voir la puissance
pour résister à ces choses
ces choses
ne peuvent pas caractériser
un vrai enfant de Dieu
il n'est pas motivé
par la terreur
par les menaces
par la perte du salut
mais il a une joie
qu'il a expérimenté
qui est dans tel ordre
tellement et infiniment
supérieur
au plaisir
charnel
qu'il avait goûté
qui lui rend capable
de ne plus vivre
dans la pratique
de ces choses
et donc là
c'est plutôt
pour les Galates
qui se rappellent
de leur arrière-plan
dans une nation païenne
et dans cette liste
nous voyons aussi
plusieurs
de ces péchés
charnels
qui sont manifestés ici
ce sont les comportements
les plus bestiales
même si l'animosité
les inlimitiés
dévorer les uns d'autre
est très bestiale
aussi de la part
des pharisiens
avec leur animosité
de l'autre côté
nous voyons aussi
les comportements bestiales
de ceux qui se sont
qui se laissent
diriger
attention
par leurs désirs
les plus
les moins nobles
les plus charnels
au lieu de chercher
les plaisirs
les plus nobles
et donc ici on voit
par exemple
or les œuvres de la chair
sont manifestes
sont l'impudicité
l'impureté
la dissolution
et là bien sûr
ce sont les plaisirs
sexuels
nous nous comportons
comme des bêtes sauvages
ce lieu
de nous rapporter
envers les mariages
selon les cadres
de l'amour chrétien
l'amour d'alliance
nous tombons
dans ces péchés
par contre
infiniment plus efficace
que de faire
des séries
de prédications
contre la pornographie
par exemple
une église
va conduire
les personnes
à la sainteté
s'ils ont la capacité
de connaître
la joie
trouvée
dans la sainteté
plaire Dieu
être
en intime communion
avec Christ
les purs de coeur
verront Dieu
intimité
avec le Saint-Esprit
qui nous fait
et qui nous donne
la capacité
d'avoir une telle sorte
des joies
qui est appelée
ineffable
indescriptible
c'est
sur la joie
chrétienne
que nous trouverons
la capacité
de rénoncer
ces plaisirs
corrompus
qui nuisent
la vraie joie
elle-même
car toute joie
expérimentée
par les hommes
sans la compagnie
du Dieu créateur
c'est une joie
mêlée
avec de la culpabilité
complète
absence
de paix
même lorsqu'ils sont
en train d'égoutter
les bonnes choses
de la vie
et même
l'idolâtrie
et la magie
c'est intéressant
on a déjà étudié
ces choses
mais là
on est intéressé
à voir comment
la joie
s'oppose
de manière efficace
et manifeste
l'authenticité
de la foi de quelqu'un
un chrétien
qui est
satisfait
plein
pensez à la femme
samaritaine
elle a reçu
des lots vivantes
qu'il a tellement remplies
à pont
qu'elle a pu arrêter
de chercher
à remplir
les vies des dieux
dans sa vie
par des relations
avec des hommes
c'était la joie
de Christ
qui l'a satisfait
mais l'idolâtrie
et la magie
c'est un peu
la même chose
l'idolâtrie
c'est quand
on élève
les petites sources
des plaisirs
que Dieu nous a données
pour être réjouite
avec lui
et on les met
à la place des dieux
on imagine
que si on n'a pas
ces choses
on n'a pas la joie
on n'a pas la satisfaction
et c'est qu'est Dieu
qui est capable
de nous donner
cette satisfaction
donc l'idolâtrie
elle est aussi
une manière
de chercher
à domestiquer
Dieu
par la religion
afin que Dieu
serve à nos plaisirs
c'est une relation
c'est l'une des
plus abominables
car c'est une relation
utilitaire avec Dieu
je vais à l'église
car je sais
que les soi-disant
prophètes
vont promettre
qu'un ange
viendra pour me donner
la maison si attendue
dans un tableau d'or
je viens à l'église
non car j'anticipe
arriver à l'église
pour retrouver
les délices
de l'éternel
dans ma relation
intime avec lui
lui le cœur
de l'adoration
donc je viens à l'église
en faisant
usage des dieux
pour transformer
les circonstances
de ma vie
et là c'est
même de
tellement
tordre
la conception
biblique des prières
toutefois
ce ne soit pas
ma volonté
mais la tienne
c'est ce que Christ
nous enseigne
dans sa prière
au Gethsemane
mais aujourd'hui
on est en train
de déclarer des choses
de décréter des choses
de déterminer des choses
en mettant Dieu
contre le mur
pour servir
à sponsoriser
mon idolâtrie
mes plaisirs
charnels
donc quand on pense
la magie
attention
on a vu ça
c'est
toutes les sortes
de manières
en cherchant
comme par une baguette
magique
régler nos problèmes
sans que ça passe
par les voies
des dieux
vous vous rappelez de ça
c'est pharmaké
ça c'est lié
quelque part
à la notion
de la pharmacie
comme si les médicaments
ou la médecine
pourraient régler
tous nos problèmes
mais particulièrement
comme c'était encore
dans cette époque
mélangé
avec beaucoup
des choses
qui n'étaient pas
prouvées par la science
c'était
de transporter
trop d'attentes
qui est quelque chose
un peu mystique
magie
comme
surcellerie
par exemple
que ces choses
résourent
mes problèmes
dans ma vie
c'est
les rapports
malheureusement
des chrétiens
aujourd'hui
avec plusieurs
moyens
qui ne sont pas
prouvés par la science
plusieurs traitements
qui ne règlent pas
les problèmes
comme Dieu les règle
à la racine
confrontés directement
de manière éclairée
lorsque Jésus
va porter
pendant les sévères
de la montagne
son enseignement
contre l'anxiété
ne soyez pas inquiets
il va redresser
avant tout
la perspective
de la vie
de manière très raisonnable
comment on regarde
la vie
je me sens très fragile
très menacé
j'anticipe plutôt
un Dieu contre moi
qui ne va pas gouverner
les circonstances
pour mon bien
c'est les payants
qui pensent comme ça
pour vous
ce n'est pas comme ça
vous avez un Père Céleste
qui prend son de toutes les choses
aucun psychotrope
aucun traitement
psychanalytique
n'a la capacité
de régler
la problématique
à la racine
ce n'est pas
par la suppression
aveugle
de la culpabilité
qu'on va arriver
à surmonter nos problèmes
et donc là
l'idolâtrie de la magie
elle fait des promesses
de nous apporter
la joie
mais ça reste toujours
une joie superficielle
car elle ne passe pas
par la seule source
capable
de nous remplir
Dieu lui-même
quand nous considérons aussi
ces mots
qui ont été traduits
pour nous
comme
livre en nierie
qui à la base
signifie tout simplement
entorpecent
nous voyons une espèce
de comparaison
avec l'expérience
des joies
l'extase
sans intelligence
et la bible
elle est très intéressante
car en éphésien
chapitre 5
l'apôtre Paul dit
ne remplissez
les mots exacts
ne vous inivrez pas
par les vents
mais soyez remplis
du Saint-Esprit
quel est l'enseignement
c'est car l'esprit
de Dieu
il a la capacité
de nous communiquer
une joie similaire
une espèce d'extase
mais c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
comment cette joie
va s'exprimer
pour la suite
et c'est intéressant
c'est la soumission
mutuelle entre les chrétiens
c'est nous qui chantons
qui célébrons
et qui avons
la capacité
attention
car nous sommes en train
de déborder des joies
nous avons la capacité
de servir aux besoins
des autres
celui qui sert
comme un esclave
c'est celui qui montre
qu'il a un vrai héritage
que personne ne peut
l'ôter
il manifeste sa richesse
par sa générosité
il peut occuper une place
qui peut être perçue
comme humiliante
car il est là
en train de manifester
un débordement des joies
mais le Saint-Esprit
il nous apporte toujours
les raisons
pour notre espérance
il apporte toujours
les raisons
pour notre joie
c'est en mettant
la lumière
sur ce que Christ
a fait pour nous
à la croix
et tous les biens
qui nous sont réservés
pendant toute l'éternité
dans la gloire
que nous avons
les raisons
qui déclenchent
la joie
dans notre expérience
c'est profondément
expérimental
mais c'est aussi
profondément
informé
raisonnable
et donc
c'est pas par
les entourpessants
que nous allons trouver
le soulagement
de nos douleurs
ou la joie
véritable
et non plus
par une expérience
soit disant
d'extase
qui peut être
perçue tout simplement
comme émotionnaliste
lorsqu'on nous dit
que par là
nous sommes remplis
de Saint-Esprit
mais cette connaissance
expérimentale
de Dieu
n'est pas accompagnée
par l'information
biblique
et par la transformation
de nos vies
c'est intéressant
aussi de remarquer
cette table ici
manifestée
qui est un indice
d'un désordre
d'une insatisfaction
d'un autre ordre
on essaye
de satisfaire
par notre relation
avec la nourriture
un manquement
des joies
des consolations
des compensations
qu'on n'arrive pas
à trouver
dans notre équilibre
dans la vie
et voilà pourquoi
nous voyons de manière
très claire
les rapports
entre
la joie
étant mise
en contraste
avec toute cette
fragmentation
et tous ces désordres
dans nos vies
la joie
elle est capable
de faire face
à chacune de ces choses
c'est infiniment
plus facile
à rénoncer
ce qui est mauvais
lorsqu'on est en train
de goûter
du joie
dans notre arbre
lorsqu'on nous savons
exemple bête
si on rentre
dans une fête
où nous sommes sûrs
qu'il faut respecter
les règles à l'intérieur
pour qu'on ne soit pas
chassé
les ailes
que nous avons
pour avoir
pour pouvoir goûter
et réjouir
de ces bonnes choses
nous empêche
de rater l'opportunité
mais attention
nous savons
que même si nous échouons
dans notre parcours
des fois
nous avons
les pardons de Dieu
les cadres parfaits
pour nous restaurer
mais la diligence
authentique
organique
et naturelle
qui conduit
les chrétiens
à ne pas revenir
à la pratique
de ses péchés
elle est motivée
avant tout
et surtout
par les plaisirs
qu'il a
à plaire Dieu
tout simplement
et en plaisant
Dieu
constater
que toutes ces règles
sont pour notre bien
c'est volontaires
jusqu'à la racine
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que l'objectif
n'est pas
de réjouir
des bonnes choses
que Dieu nous donne
la première lettre
de Paul à Timothée
au chapitre 4
il dit le suivant
mais l'esprit
il dit
expressement
que dans les derniers temps
quelques-uns
abandonneront
la foi
pour s'attacher
à des esprits
trompeurs
et à des doctrines
des démons
par l'hypocrisie
de ceux qui parlent
en trompeurs
ayant la conscience
cautérisée
interdissant
de se marier
en ordonnant
de s'abstenir
des aliments
que Dieu a créés
pour être reçus
avec action
des grâces
par ceux
qui sont croyants
et qui ont connu
la vérité
car tout ce qui
Dieu a créé
est bon
et rien n'est
à rejeter
pourvu qu'on les reçoive
avec action
des grâces
car il est sanctifié
par la parole
et par la prière
qu'est-ce qui sont
considérés ici
comme doctrine
des démons
c'est une austerité
absolue
qui arrive presque
à supprimer
toutes les joies
qu'on pourrait goûter
dans la vie
des choses légitimes
la vraie joie
n'est pas tout simplement
d'être centré
focalisé sur Christ
ça c'est le cœur
et le sang
de notre joie
mais c'est de savoir
maximiser notre relation
avec Christ
en faisant
bon usage
des choses
qu'il a créées
donc
qu'est-ce qui va
déterminer
mon rapport
envers chacune
de ces ères
de la vie
ma sexualité
ma relation
avec mon épouse
et mes enfants
qu'est-ce qui va
déterminer
ma relation
avec
beaucoup
d'autres
sources
même la communion
la religion
même les vents
qu'est-ce qui va
déterminer
la limite
c'est de me demander
est-ce que mon rapport
envers cette chose
est en train de plaire
mon Seigneur
est-ce que cela
peut être vu
et perçu
cette dose
si on peut dire comme ça
comme quelque chose
qui plaît l'éternel
et qui exprime pour moi
l'amour des dieux
pour moi
à la fin des comptes
c'est la joie
que nous avons
en Christ
qui détermine
la manière
dont on arrive
à dire non
à la prochaine
goutte de vent
qui représenterait
le péché
c'est d'avoir
plus en zèle
pour plaire
l'éternel
que ces autres choses
les rapports
entre la joie
et les œuvres
de la chair
les contrastes
il est enraciné
dans ce que Thomas Charles
a appelé
la puissance
exclusive
d'une nouvelle affection
pour lui
l'échéement
le plus court
pour qu'un chrétien
se débarrasse
de ses péchés
n'est pas si temps
de démontrer
toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles
il devrait échapper
à cause des punitions
ou des difficultés
qu'il trouvera
dans sa vie
mais c'est de
diriger son égard
envers la joie
qui ne peut qu'être
trouvée
dans la beauté
de Christ
dans son serment
qui est devenu
très connu
la structure très courte
je vous dis
juste les titres
le cœur humain
est dominé
par des affections
quand vous êtes
esclave
dans un péché
charnel
c'est car
vous trouvez
quelques plaisirs
là-dedans
la répression
n'est pas suffisante
c'est sa théorie
car même la loi
n'était pas capable
mais avec toutes les menaces
c'est la loi
elle n'a jamais été capable
pour conduire un pharisien
à obéir la loi
comme il faut
elle a provoqué
plutôt
la répression
elle va plutôt
provoquer la tentation
le plus on essaye
de réprimer
le plus on rentre
dans un cercle
vicieux
où on retombe
chaque fois plus
profondément
la clé du changement
est une affection
plus grande
même avant
ma conversion
je me rappelle
très bien
que je n'allais pas
arrêter de faire
quelque chose
qui me plaisait
sauf si quelqu'un
m'appelait
à m'inviter
à faire quelque chose
d'encore plus plaisant
et l'objet
suprême
du plaisir
pour l'être humain
c'est
la connaissance
l'expérience
la contemplation
de l'amour du Christ
voici ce qu'il dit
Thomas Charles
l'amour des dieux
dans les Christes
est la seule puissance
qui puisse expulser
les affections pécheresses
du cœur au monde
ce que la loi
ne peut pas faire
l'évangile l'est fait
non par la répression
de la mauvaise affection
mais par l'activation
de la plus grande affection
le cœur humain
ne se débarrasse
jamais d'une affection
sans en adopter
une autre
l'homme ne pourra
jamais expulser
une affection
du cœur
sauf par l'introduction
d'une affection
plus grande
qui l'enchasse
vous comprenez
les rapports
et la capacité
de cette joie
trouvée en Jésus Christ
d'exterminer
dans notre milieu
les tentations
pharisaïques
d'un côté
et de l'autre côté
les tentations
envers les péchés
les plus abominables
qui caractérisent
la vie des païens
pour nous
on va devoir
s'arrêter ici
aujourd'hui
nous allons continuer
pour considérer
de manière plus pratique
comment cultiver
cette joie
comment comprendre
et aujourd'hui
le plus important
à retenir
c'est que
si nous sommes
en Christ
on a déjà goûté
de cette joie
et ça devrait être
l'objet
de notre désir
le plus profond
et le plus constant
nous devons être
déterminés
et résolus
c'est à notre disposition
à cultiver cette joie
et nous devons
être sûrs
que cette joie
est le seul moyen
efficace
et capable
d'enlever
de notre milieu
en tant qu'église
les attitudes
légalistes
envers Dieu
et envers les autres
et les péchés
des tentations
charnelles
qu'on peut faire face
dans nos vies
nous devons nous rappeler
que le Seigneur
Jésus Christ
a démontré
qu'il est
l'objet suprême
de notre joie
car
il a opéré
par l'évangile
attention
la délivrance
de notre plus grand malheur
il a assuré
il a garanti
qu'il nous amènera
dans la gloire future
on va réjouir
de toutes les bonnes choses
que Dieu a créées
dans sa perfection
et on doit se rappeler
que la plus grande joie
du ciel
des anges
des dieux lui-même
est la communion intime
et la contemplation
de notre Seigneur Jésus Christ
dans sa pleine gloire